good morning believe nation today's
messages have fun over to you Stanley TV
go how do you keep the creative juices
flowing to keep creating work over the
years greed is probably one of the
reasons no actually I'm doing what I
enjoy doing it's like other men like to
play golf so they play golf every chance
they can see you don't say to him how
come you're playing golf today you
played last week was the same with me to
me it is such fun creating characters
writing stories even doing interviews
even though i kin dear most of what the
guy says to me but it's an exciting life
and when you do something that you know
the fans seem to enjoy that gives you
such satisfaction you don't want to stop
I think fun is vastly underestimated in
the world of entrepreneurship I think we
we tend to talk about getting customers
and come up with business ideas and
raising capital but we don't often talk
about having fun and people don't see
fun as a success factor where I think if
you are not having fun in your business
you're not going to have success now not
every day is going to be super fun not
every day is gonna be the best day of
your life you're going to have a ton of
challenges and it's the fun that kind of
gets you through dealing with all the
crap in your business I definitely
relate to this message from staying
because you know I'm creating videos for
you guys and I have fun doing it and I'm
coming up with new ideas for where it
can take a channel and I think too many
people get boxed into doing the same
thing over and over and over and over
and over again because it's what the
customer wants maybe it's what it's
always worked for you and I might be fun
at the start but then you want to try
new stuff right entrepreneurs we're
creative we're ambitious you want to do
new things and stretch ourselves we've
come up with new ideas and you need to
go explore those and you need to
continue to evolve your business to
continue to have fun because when you
stop having fun in your business that's
when it starts to
so the question today today is how do
you have fun in your business leaving
the comments below I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press